♪ A travers les époques, les dangers ! ♪
♪ Une grande aventure les appelle ♪
♪C'est, c'est, c'est, c'est l'épopée temporelle ! ♪
Narrateur : L'épopée Temporelle continue
Nos héros sont toujours à la recherche du Docteur Simon, le père d'Iris
Nous les avions laissé dans un bateau en feu
Au large de l'île de la Réunion
en l'an 1710, Prêts à se faire découper par
LaBuse, le célèbre pirate sanguinaire...
Après tout, il a une hache, il faut bien qu'il s'en serve :) <3
Thomas : MAIS POURQUOI VOUS VOULEZ NOUS TUER ?! ON S'CONNAIT MÊME PAS !
LaBuse : Bon les gens c'est pas compliqué ! Soit ils me donnent de l'argent
pour tuer quelqu'un, soit J'LES TUE !
Le robot : Très binaire comme conception de la vie. J'aime beaucoup.
Iris : Euh.. on est plus de la première catégorie
LaBuse : AH INTERRESSANT ! Pour 5 000 pièces,
je tue qui vous voulez !
Thomas : On cherche un scientifique..
LaBuse : AH ! Y'a un scientifique qui est arrivé y'a pas longtemps !
Vous voulez le tuer ...?
Iris : Ah nan !
LaBuse : J'comprend pas
ET VOUS SAVEZ CE QUE JE FAIS QUAND JE COMPREND PAS ?
Thomas : Vous-vous voulez tuer...?
LaBuse : ABSOLUMENT !
VOUS ALLEZ GOUTER A MA HACHE !
ELLE A LE GOÛT DE LA MORT
Iris : Non attendez ! Si, si vous avez raison ! On veut le tuer ce scientifique !
Thomas : Tu veux tuer ton père? Vous vous entendez si mal que ça ?
Iris  : CHUT !
C'est un stratagème. Il nous mène à lui  hop ! on se téléporte !
LaBuse : ALORS SUIVEZ MOI ! JE SAIS OU LE TROUVER ! CE SERA 6 000 PIECES !
Iris : 6 000 ?! Mais tout  l'heure c'était--
LaBuse : QUAND ON ME FAIT TOURNER EN BOURRIQUE,
LE PRIX AUGMENTE...
Le Robot : Sinon, ce bateau est en feu.
On peut peut être négocier plus tard ?
LaBuse : VOICI MON BATEAU ! EN ROUTE !
Le Robot : C'est vous qui avez mis le feu à l'autre bateau ?
LaBuse :Ouais ehehehehehh !
Le Robot : Pourquoi donc ?
LaBuse : PARCEQUE J'SUIS UN PIRATE ! JE TUE TOUT LE MONDE ET JE
MET L'FEU ! (oh non un pyromane :( !)
Iris : Bah... vous pourriez pas prendre le bateau et le revendre plutôt ?
LaBuse : A QUOI BON VIVRE SI JE PEUX PAS BRULER DES BATEAUX ?
ACCROCHEZ VOUS J'OUVRE LES VOILES ! ON EST PAS TRES LOIN !
Iris : Hum..LaBuse ?J'ai une mission très spéciale pour vous
Une mission que seul un grand pirate peut remplir !
LaBuse : JE SUIS LE PLUS GRAND DES PIRATES !
Iris : Vous nous menez à ce scientifique, mais vous ne le tuez pas tout de suite !
LaBuse : Vous voulez que je torture ? *rire psychopathe*  VOUS COMMENCEZ A ME PLAIRE !
Iris : NON NON NON NON ! Vous le tuerez quand l'un d'entre nous dira le signal !
Et ce signale ce sera le mot... hum..
hum...
Eliott: Pomme!
LaBuse: Pomme?
Iris: Voilà! Pomme! Facile, hein? Vous le tuez pas
tant que l'un d'entre nous n'a pas dit "pomme"
LaBuse: COMME VOUS VOUDREZ! J'entends à des lieues à la ronde!
J'vais pas l'louper!
Iris: Euh... Eliott, pourquoi "pomme"?
Eliott: C'est mon mot de passe interne.
Thomas: Ah, t'es pas super sécurisé...
Eliott: Personne ne veut pirater une machine à café.
LaBuse: Meurtre plus signal secret...
Ca fera 7.000 pièces! Direction la taverne!
Thomas: Je sais pas pourquoi mais j'ai l'impression que tout ça est un très mauvais plan
LaBuse: En route!
*Musique de fond*
*Ouverture de porte et cris de pirates*
LaBuse: Le scientifique vient dans cette taverne tous les jours en début de soirée.
On pourra pas l'rater! HAHAHA! Tout l'monde l'insulte quand il entre!
Tavernier: Bonsoir, qu'est-ce que j'vous sers?
LaBuse: Du rhum pour ces gars-là, et pour moi!
Thomas: Alors de l'eau pour moi... J'ai assez bu au Moyen-Age...
LaBuse: De l'eau? WAHA!
T'as du cran, j'aime ça! *Tape dans le dos*
Thomas: Aïe!
LaBuse: J'vais aux latrines, j'me retiens depuis 2 jours.
J'aime PAS faire caca sur mon bateau. Et touchez pas à mon verre, hein!
VOSU SAVEZ C'QUE J'FAIS AUX GENS QUI TOUCHENT A MON VERRE?!
Iris: J'imagine que vous...
LaBuse: JE LES TUE!
Iris: Et bah voilà, c'est c'que j'pensais...
Tavernier: Et voilà les 3 rhums et... hihihi
Un verre d'eau pour le courageux!
Thomas: Merci!
Thomas: Iris, c'est fou toutes les aventures qu'on vit ensemble, hein?
On a frôlé la mort, et c'est dans ces moments là qu'on réalise que l'amour...
Iris: Mais c'est vrai qu'on a complètement oublié de te déposer chez toi!
Thomas: Quoi?
Eliott: Je peux le faire immédiatement.
Thomas: NON NON, non, on a une mission, j'veux rencontrer
ton père qui est probablement un grand homme!
Iris: Non, non, je t'arrête tout de suite
Mon père n'est PAS un grand homme. C'est un homme qui a jamais levé le nez
de ses inventions pour regarder le dessin que je lui avais fait.
Quand j'étais ado, j'suis partie 1 semaine sans le prévenir.
Quand j'suis rentrée il m'a juste dit "Tas passé une bonne soirée?"
Thomas: D'accord...Ouah! Bah il a quand même inventé la machine à voyager dans le temps!
Iris: Il a jamais su vivre le moment présent, alors tu vois, j'trouve ça un peu lâche d'essayer d'en partir
Thomas: Ben, je...
Moi, si tu me faisais un dessin, j'l'accrocherais au frigo, parce que...
c'est aussi ça un couple, c'est aussi de petites attentions qui font plaisir...
Eliott: Ecoutez là-bas
Pirates: -Eh! Le scientifique!
-Regardez qui que v'là. C'est l'scientifique
Iris: Ca doit être mon père! Allons-y!
Pirates: -Alors l'scientifique! Tu "scientifises quoi en c'moment?
-Bah expliquez-la nous votre histoire de... "gravitationnalité"!
Scientifique: Et bien, lorsqu'un objet tombe, en vérité, il est attiré par la terre!
Pirates: -HAHAHAHAHA
Iris: Mais c'est pas du tout mon père!
Eliott: IDENTIFICATION! C'est le scientifique: ISAAC NEWTON!
Pirate: Donc si j'te soulève comme ça...
Et que j'te jette par terre...
*jette Newton*
Newton: Aïe!
Pirate: Mais j't'ai rien fait mon brave, t'as juste été attiré par la Terre!
Pirates: AHAHAHA!!!!!
Newton: A vrai dire, vous m'avez projeté au sol, donc vous avez exercé une force en plus de celle de la gravité!
Il faudrait plutôt me soulever!
Pirate: GNA HA HA!
Newton: Vous me portez à bout de bras,
et vous me lâchez!
AH! Aïe!
Pirates: HAHAHAHAHA!
Newton: Intéressant, non? Vous n'avez exercé aucune force de propulsion!
Et pourtant, j'a filé droit vers le sol.
C'est la terre qui m'a attiré
Pirates: -Les gars! Et si on essayait dans l'eau? Pour voir si il est attiré DANS L'FOND!
Pirates: -OUAI!
Newton: Non, ça c'est Archimède! On nous confond parfois
Pirates: -ALLEZ! On l'emmène au port! On l'attache à un gros caillou, et on fait une expérience SCIENTIFIQUE!
Iris: Si Isaac Newton est là, c'est forcément en rapport avec mon père!
Il faut l'aider! Hé, pssst... Monsieur Newton!
Newton: Oui?
Iris: Préparez-vous à courir... HE, LES GARS!
RHUM GRATUIT POUR LES PREMIERS AU BAR!
Pirates: -OUAI, ALLEZ!
Iris: Suivez-moi, courez!
Eliott: C'est bon, nous sommes à l'abri dans cette ruelle.
Newton: Ah, merci mes braves!
Iris: Il faut qu'on se dépêche avant que  LaBuse revienne parce que... à votre avis, il fait quoi au gens
qui s'enfuient pendant qu'il est aux toilettes?
Thomas: OH! JE SAIS! Il les tue, c'est ça?
Iris: Oh, super, Einstein... Mais, Monsieur Newton, qu'est ce que vous faites là? Vous vivez pas en Angleterre?
Newton: Si, mais je suis venu ici pour réfléchir au calme à une nouvelle théorie...
Et prendre un peu de vacances, ce sont clairement les PIRES vacances de ma vie.
Je suis un grand scientifique très respecté dans mon pays!
Savez-vous comment j'ai découvert la théorie de la gravitation universelle?
Je marchais sous un arbre, quand soudain, une...
Iris: NON NE DITES PAS CE MOT, par pitié, LaBuse n'est pas loin
Newton: Une... Une poir m'est tombée sur la tête!
Iris: Ah! Ouf!
Attendez, une poire? Mais dans les livres on nous a toujours dit que c'était...
Newton: Et j'ai toujours été passioné par les sciences, depuis que je suis haut comme trois...
Iris: NON, non!
Newton: Chatons qu'on aurait mis les uns sur les autres,
Iris: Ouf!
Newton: J'étais très mignon!
Iris: Monsieur Newton, auriez-vous rencontré un autre scientifique?
Newton: Tout à fait! Vous voyez, un certain Docteur Simon
M'a approché pour en savoir plus sur une de mes théories abandonnées sur l'"infiniment moyen"!
Et s'il y avait quelque chose entre
l'infiniment grand et l'infiniment petit: ce n'est ni petit ni grand,
ni fini, ni infini, ni passé, ni présent,
ni mou, ni dur, ni froid,ni chaud, ni...
Iris, Oui bon merci, on a compris! Tu m'étonnes qu'il a abandonné cette théorie!
Mais, pourquoi mon père s'est intéressé à ça?
Newton: Ca m'a fait plaisir de parler avec quelqu'un qui me comprenait, mais ensuite, il m'a volé mon carnet et il a disparu!
Iris: Et il a dit quelque chose avant de partir?
Genre... "Allez salut, je vais aller à..."?
Newton: Parfaitement!
Iris: OK, cool!
Il a précisé qu'il partait chez les Mayas pour y déposer une relique
Iris: Les Mayas?
Eliott: Une relique?
Newton, Oui, une relique qui contient une...
LaBuse: POOOOOOOOOOOOMME!
Newton: OOOOOOH!
Thomas: Votre Isaac Newton vient d'se faire buter par la hache de LaBuse
Iris: Mais LaBuse, t'abuses! On a pas dit le signal!
LaBuse: Si, MOI, j'l'ai dit! Vous avez dit qu'on l'tuait pas tant que l'un d'ente nous disait pas "pomme"!
J'ai dit "pomme"
Eliott: C'est logique, on ne peut pas lui reprocher ça...
LaBuse: Merci!
Iris: Mais c'est quoi cette histoire?Mon père a déposé une relique chez les Mayas?
Eliott: J'ai la trace du passage du Docteur Simon dans la civilisation Maya en l'an...1524!
LaBuse: Maintenant donnez-moi mes 8.000 PIECES
VOUS SAVEZ C'QUE J'FAIS AUX GENS QUI M'PAYENT PAS?
Thomas: Vous êtes sympa et vous passez l'éponge?
LaBuse: JE LES TUUUUUE!
Thomas: J'aurais essayé...
Iris: Ah non, non mais bien sûr! On va vous payer!
LaBuse: Bon alors?
Iris: Attendez ne bougez pas surtout, je les cherche...
Je les cherche...Eliott?
LaBuse: Vous les avez ou pas?
Eliott: Retemporalisation dans... 5... 4... 3... 2...
LaBuse: Vous les avez pas? JE VAIS VOUS TUER!
Iris: ON BOUUUUUUGE!
Eliott: Nous voici dans le sud du Mexique en 1524
La température extérieure est très précisément de 29° centigrade
La faune sauvage se compose d'insectes, de lamas, de...
Thomas: Vous aussi ça vous fait un truc bizarre dans les intestincs un voyage dans le temps?
Iris: Non, ça, c'est l'eau que t'as bu dans la taverne. Et tu pourras pas dire qu'on t'a pas prévenu!
LaBuse: Bon sang, qu'est-ce qui s'est passé?!
Thomas, Eliott et Iris: LaBuse?
LaBuse: Il faisait nuit, et là il fait jour! Où qu'on est? Par quelle magie? Ce sont de nouvelles terres?
Ca sent le trésor à plein nez!
Préparez mes 8.000 pièces, je vail piller tout le monde et je reviens! HAHAHAHAHA!
Thomas: Nickel, on vient de lâcher un pirate sanguinaire chez les Mayas...
Narrateur: Mais où peut bien être le Docteur Simon?
Que va t-il arriver à nos héros?
Et qu'en est-il de cette drôle de relique? Tout ça, je le sais!
Vous aimeriez bien être à ma place, hein?
Rendez-vous au prochain épisode de l'Epopée Temporelle!
Cyprien: Merci d'avoir écouté le 5e épisode de l'Epopée Temporelle
N'hésite pas à t'abonner et à mettre un pouce en l'air!
Et on s'retrouve dans 2 semaines! Et oui c'est les vacances! #Jambon